hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make math a
lot less stressful so in this video what
we're going to do is react until you on
learning about how to solve equations
and here we're going to be working with
multi-step equations so in some of the
previous videos I talked about one-step
and two-step equations but here we're
gonna actually talk about multiple steps
and it's good to have a framework for
solving these types of equations and the
three steps I like to think of when I do
these problems is right here so let's
take a look so number one you want to
simplify the left and the right sides of
the equation what I mean by that is you
want to try to combine like terms on the
left side you know condense it down as
much as you can combine like terms on
the right side condense it down as much
as you can here basically it's like a
clean up step or trying to you know
clean it up simplify it a little bit
before you get to the next step which is
to get the variables on one side and the
numbers on the other side so what you're
trying to do is at that point are trying
to separate them and it doesn't matter
whether you get the variables on the
left and the numbers on the right or the
other way around the key thing is that
you want to separate them and get them
on opposite sides and then the last step
is you always want to solve just for one
of the variables so you don't want to X
or 3z you just want one of that variable
so usually at that last step were going
to be multiplying or dividing but we'll
take a look at some examples and I'll
show you what I mean so this first
example you can see there's quite a bit
going on here but what we want to do is
we want to just try to clean up on that
first step just simplify the left side
and the right side as much as we can so
let's do that first thing we're gonna do
here is we're going to distribute the
three okay the three is right next to
the parenthesis when two things are
right next to each other without
anything in between that means that
they're multiplied together right so
this is going to be 3x minus 6 so 3
times 2 plus 4 equals now the 2 I'm
going to do the same thing I'm going to
distribute so that's 2x plus 2 now we're
still on step number one I want to see
if there's anything else I can simplify
I want to try to condense it down as
much as I can so that's going to be 3x
and the negative 6 and the positive 4 we
can add together that's going to be
negative 2 or you could write it as
minus 2 equals 2x plus 2 so now we're
done with that first step so to speak so
it's not necessarily just 1
you know operation it might be a couple
different operations but it's that kind
of I group it as a first step second
step you want to get the variables on
one side and the numbers on the opposite
side it's up to you whichever one looks
simpler I would go with that method but
I think here for this one I'm going to
get the variables on the left so if you
want to get the variables on the left
that's like saying you want to get rid
of them on the right so to get rid of
something what do you do you want to do
the opposite so here you can see this is
a positive 2x positive and plus they go
together so positive 2x means you're
adding 2x the opposite of doing that is
to subtract 2x from both sides of the
equation okay left and right sides I'm
keeping them separated I like to draw a
line but it's up to you and now we're
just going to add straight down so 3x
minus 2x is 1x minus 2 these are going
to cancel that gives you 0 and that's
going to give us 2 okay now we've
completed step number 2 so now we're
going to step number 3 we're going to
solve for one of the variable okay well
actually we are still on step number 2
because we have to get the numbers on
the opposite side so instead of
subtracting 2 here let's do the opposite
let's add 2 okay so we get x equals 4
now we've separated the variables are on
the left the numbers are on the right
and we've accomplished step number 3 at
the same time because we just have one
of the variable left over do we have
just one X so we know our solution is x
equals 4 if you want to check your work
just go ahead and put 4 back in for X
and simplify and make sure that the left
side and the right side are the same
okay let's look at another example so in
this example we're going to follow the 3
steps so first step is to see if you can
condense these terms condense these
terms simplify kind of like a clean up
step it doesn't look like we can do that
because these are variables these are
numbers same thing here so we're on to
step number 2 and that's to get the
variables on one side and the numbers on
the other side now I'm going to give you
another option here you see how this is
a fraction divided by 3 and you could
think of this as a fraction as well
anything divided by 1 is itself what you
might want to do is multiply everything
in this equation by 3 what that does is
it clear
the denominators three times three would
just give you 1 X 4 times 3 is 12 2
times 3 gives you 6 X and 3 times 19 is
57 as long as you multiply everything in
the equation left and right sides by the
same number it's going to be the same
equation so now what we're gonna do is
we're gonna get the variables on one
side and the numbers on the opposite
side so let's go ahead and get the
variables on the on the right side this
time and the numbers on the left so to
get the variables on the right side I'm
gonna get rid of them on the left side
how do I get rid of them by doing the
opposite now you can see this is a
positive 1x pause is like adding so I'm
going to do the opposite I'm going to
subtract 1 X like so X minus X is zero
so we're just left with 12 6 X minus 1 X
is 5x + 57 plus 0 is 57 ok now the
variables are on the right we want to
get the numbers on the left to get rid
of this 57 see how we're adding 57 so
I'm going to subtract 57 from both sides
and so here we have 5x equals what does
this come out to here negative 45
positive 12 and a negative 57 added
together is negative 45 now we're on the
last step solve for just one of the
variable we just want to find out what
1x equals so because the 5 and the X are
right next to each other that means
they're multiplied together we're going
to do the opposite of multiplying by 5
we're going to divide by 5 whatever we
do to the right side we have to do the
left side to keep it balanced negative
45 divided by 5 is negative 9 and there
we go x equals negative 9 if you want to
check your work you can take the
negative 9 and put it back in for
wherever you see X simplify the left
side simplify the right side see if
they're the same if they're the same you
know you've got it right okay let's look
at the last example this is a long one
you can see there's a lot going on here
so we're going to follow the three steps
again we're going to simplify the left
and right sides as much as we can before
going on so first step is to combine
like terms so we've got a negative 2x
and a positive 5x you remember when
you're doing this you want to capture
the sign that's just it to the left or
in front of the term that you're working
with so see how I'm capture
that plus sign that tells me this is
positive 5x negative 2x which adds up to
3 X 7 and positive 3 is 10 okay over
here same thing 5x + 3 X is 8 X + 4 X is
12 X - 8 okay so we completed step
number one now step number two we want
to get the variables on one side numbers
on the opposite side I'm gonna get the
variables on the left I usually like to
get them on the left numbers on the
right it doesn't matter you just wanna
make sure they're on opposite sides but
to get the variables on the left is
another way of saying to get rid of them
on the right so how do you eliminate
something you do the opposite so since
this is a 12 X a positive 12x that's
like adding 12 X we want to do the
opposite we want to subtract 12x and you
want to make sure you're doing it to
both sides to keep the equation balanced
right so 3x minus 12x is negative 9x
plus 10 and just bring you the 10 down
12x minus 12x is 0 negative 8 plus 0 is
negative 8 now we want to get the
numbers on the right side which is
another way of saying we have to get rid
of them on the left side so to get rid
of something you do the opposite instead
of adding 10 we're going to subtract 10
I like to draw a line and you get
negative 18 and negative 9x ok now we're
on to step number 3 solve for one of the
variable we've got negative 9x we just
want positive 1x so we're gonna do the
opposite of multiplying by negative 9
we're gonna divide both sides by
negative 9 like that okay that negative
9 divided by negative 9 is positive 1
because anything divided by itself is 1
right and negative 18 divided by
negative 9 is positive 2 so that's it
and again if you want to check your work
you can put it back in simplify and make
sure the left sides and the right sides
you know they're equal and you know
you've got it right so I hope you're
enjoying these videos subscribe to the
channel check out some of my past videos
and I've got more videos like this
coming for you in the future so stay
tuned and I'll see you in the next video